皆さんこんにちは私は朝の梅と申します
私は福祉活動家ですえっと福祉活動家って
いうのは tx 札幌の方がネーミングし
てくれましたちょっと気に入っているので
これからそれでやってみようかなと思って
ます福祉の仕事をしてます
福祉になぜか変わったかというと
ボランティアです
たまたま25年くらい前に新聞で
ボランティア募集っていうのがあって
おおっちょっとってみるかなみたいな
気持ちでした一回やってあ楽しかったなぁ
で終わるつもりでした
だけどその時一緒に行った人に1回じゃ
わかんない事であるよ
続けないと見えないことってあるからって
言われて
なかなか続けるも載ってなかった私にとっ
てその言葉がちょっと大きくってちょっと
続けてみるかな
で
2型
今までなんだかんだといいながら続いて
ます
でこの続けるって事で
見えることっていうのも確かにあるんです
よね
あの自分の考えがいろいろ変わってきまし
た
まずまだ始めた頃に8すすきのの
ロックンロールのバーでチャリティー
コンサート行ったことがあります隣に
ストレッチャーっていう8ベッドのような
車いすに乗っている男の子がいました
この彼は違いますこの彼は派
今うちで8織物の仕事をしてくれている
からです
えっとうちの
会社のヘルパーを連れてパンクロックに
行ったり
た2を入れに行ったり髪を染めに行ったり
してますちなみに今はターコイズブルーの
髪を消しています
でそのボランティアに行った時の彼は
もっともっと重い障害で涎たらしてて
中を見てて音楽なんか
聞こえてるんじゃないか別れてないんじゃ
ないかと私は思ってました
お母さんがこの子音楽大好きなんだよねー
とかいっても
それってただお母さんの自己満足で彼は
うるさいところに連れてこられて
かわいそうにぐらい思ってました
ランダー盛り上がってきてみんなダンスが
を取り始めたので私はその彼の手を握って
を撮りました
そしたらその彼の片方の手の
中指だけがきっちりとリズム刻んでたの
私ものすごいショックだったの音楽なんか
全然わかってないって聞こえてないと思っ
てたその彼ちゃんとわかってて音楽楽しん
でてこっちのこと全部伝わってるんだって
すごいショックだったの
それから意識がない寝たきりだって言わ
れる人にもこっちの気持ちって伝わってる
んだ聞こえてるんだわかってるんだって
思うようになりました
もしかしたら動物とか植物にも本当は
伝わっているのかもしれません
私の団体は札幌の雪まつりの時に
ボランティアの派遣運営をしている団体
です
今はそれ以外にもいろいろ活動してます
けど
で
私はだんだん運営の方の仕事になってきた
ので
なんか文句ばっかりボランテサンに言わ
れるし
責任取らされるのは出しだし
なーんかはだ何で私ばっかりやってん
だろうなぁのために私こんなことやってん
だろう
もうやめるかなーと思ってた頃に一本店は
きましたボランティアお願いします
で私はボランティアさんにそのお宅まで
行って雪まつり見てもらってまた帰って来
てもらうという
をコーディネートしました
でその後すぐに手紙が来ました手紙には
その奥さんから
介護10年間続けてました
たいものの時も急いで帰ってくるぐらい
あとはずっと二人きりで生活してました
出かけるのは病院に行く時以外どこにも
行ったことありませんでした
雪まつり本当に楽しかったです
ボランティアさんに家まで送ってもらって
ドアを開けた後
主人が私にありがとうと言ってくれました
10年間一度も言ってもらえなかった言葉
でした
本当にありがとうございました
って書ける自信がつきました
これから二人でいろんなところに出かけ
たいと思いますというお手紙でした
私はそのご夫婦には会ってません
ボランティアもしてないし
でも私はすっごい嬉しかったの
あ
なんかやっててよかっ
で
ちょっと大変でもっていうかすっごい大変
だったんだけどそれでも何かこんな
ちょっといいことがあったら続けるかやる
なぁと思ってもうちょっと続けてみるかな
と思いました
あのその後夫婦とは会ったことがないし私
はそのご夫婦からもらった元気で今もまだ
続けていることをそのご夫婦は全く知ら
ない
でも私はその後夫婦にいつも感謝してます
最近ペイフォワードっていう言葉聞いた
ことありませんか映画にもなりました
調べてみると8
先に支払う
あと
親切にしてもらう前に親切にする
親切にしてもらった人と別の人物に上つの
施設をする
そんな意味があるそうです
私はそんなことをもっとずっと前に体験し
たことがありました
まだね子育て大変な時
すごい大変だったら知らない女性がやって
来ていいよ赤ちゃん見ててあげるよって
言われた
知らない人だったしいや大丈夫です自分で
やれますって言ったらその人が大丈夫よ私
も子供が小さい時知らない人に手伝って
もらったの
今はそのお礼をしてるの
お礼させて
その代わりあなたが子育て終わった時に誰
か大変そうなお母さんに手伝ってあげてっ
て
私そんなお礼の仕方ってあるんだなあって
その時思ってました
今で言うペイフォワードですよね
日本では今ねああ昔音をくりって言って
江戸時代には普通に行われてたことだそう
です恩送り
その名残で
情けは人のためならずという諺があるそう
です
情けは人のためならず
情けをかけるとその人のためにならないと
私は思っていて
厳しいことがあると情けは人の為ならず
って言って優しくしないという風にしてた
んだけど
逆の意味でした
情けをかけることは
その人のためだけじゃなくて自分や周りに
いいことなんだよっていう意味
この中にもそうだったのかって思う人い
ませんか
ねそれが御送り
恩返しっていうのは簡単なんだと思います
何かやってもらった人にお礼する
なんかもらえばお返しする
私のお友達にものすごいを買いお金持ちが
いて私にいっぱい高級品くれる人があり
ます
こんなねちっちゃいキャビア1個1万円を
5個とか
ソフトね私やもうこんなにもらっても返せ
ないわーって言ったら彼女が違う違う
私あなたと言うとすごい楽しいからそのお
礼に
頂き物のおすそわけしてるだけだから気に
しないでって言ってもらってそれからは
遠慮なくもらってますが
ねだけどあーなんか
品物やお金じゃなく
時間でも返せることってあるんだなって
その時ちょっと思いました
でも恩返しって
白ヤギさんと黒ヤギさんの歌のように
ふたりいる間は続くかもしれないけど
どっちがどっちかがいなくなっちゃったら
終わりのものですよね
恩返しだけど恩送りっていうのは
もし自分がスタートだとしたら
ちょっともらえるものはないかもしれんで
もその代わりちゃんと送ることができたら
それはえいえんに
世代を超えて続くもんなんじゃないかなっ
て思います
またちょっと子育ての時に戻りますけど私
がその子育てで大変な時両親はブラジルに
いたので子供と荷物を持って一つブラジル
言ってました
で
すぐにもちっぱいあの頃だからねなんかで
新巻鮭3本持ってこいとかわけわからな
いって
何か言われてそれを持って子供二人連れて
いってたんだけど
海外は寝床も困らなかったみんな手伝って
くれたし荷物運んでくれたし知らない人も
1回バスに乗って後ろの席しか空いて
なかったから後ろの席に子どもと言ったら
みんな金前に乗れ前にのれっていう
で仕方なく前に行ったら前の人はもう普通
に代わってくれましたはいはいここに座っ
てってそして
前に乗ったほうが早くおりれていい
でしょってっ
後ろに乗ったら時間かかるでしょ
あなたが早くおりれていいでしょうそして
バズもそれだけ早く出発スって来ていい
でしょうって
なんか親切って
なんか効率的なことでもあるんだなって
ちょっとその時思いました
で
やっと日本についていっ
ところがね日本はねだっても手伝ってくれ
ませんでした
荷物なんか持ってくれる人いないし席
なんか変わってくれる人なんか全然いなく
て
その頃の日本って私最低だなっ
もう大嫌いでした
妄想雷はもう日本から出ようって思う
ぐらい
ただ
一回だけ自分が
一人でバスに乗ったことがあったんです
途中から
杖をついたおじいちゃんが歩くのもやっと
でバスに乗ってきました
私よりはちょっと離れたところに立ったん
だけど
その横にいる若い男の子は全く
避ける気配はなく
その周りの人も誰も避ける気配がなく私は
こっちで
いやー川田あげればいいのにやっぱり日本
って最低
でじゃあいざ自分が変わろうと思ったら
私も言えなかったの
なんかここから歩いて言って席変わります
よっていうのが
偽善者のように思われるんじゃないかとか
年寄り扱いされするなと怒られるんじゃ
ないかとかなんかだんだん次の駅で降りる
のかもとかリハビリに頑張ってるのかもと
かなんかわけわからないことを思いながら
a なんかこう変われなかったんだよねで
自分でモードすごいへこみましたなんだ私
も言えないんだ
もう一つなんであの時自分から代わって
くださいって言わなかったんだろう
どう変わってくださいって言ったら変わっ
てもらうからはやる買われたんじゃないか
な
なんでだろう
日本人って
とっても恥ずかしがり屋で他人に何かこう
声かけるのって苦手なんのかなっ
それと手伝ってくださいって
いづらかったり
手伝いますよ席変わりますよって慣れて
ないからなんて言っていいか分からない
どうしていいか分からないだけなのかな
あってその時思いました
じゃあどうしたらいいんだろう
私は私なりに考えてはそっかまず手伝って
くださいと化石変わってくださいって言う
人を増やせばいいんだ
でデザってと化石変わってって言ったら
ああ
わかりましたよって代われる
変わることに慣れてもらえばいいのかなっ
て
特別なことじゃなくなればいいのかなっ
てっ
その頃思いました
で今もそうやっていろんな人に出かけて
もらって
声をかけていったり変わってもらったり
そんな社会できたらいいなと思って今も
ずっと続けてますもう20年超えましたが
最近全然変わりました結構席変わってくれ
ます鉄剤ますがあって声かけてもらえます
時々これ私のおかげかあってちょっと思う
でその
恩送り
私にしたらきっとその福祉の仕事は
たまたまきっかけがあってこういう仕事し
ててそれでできることなのかなって思うん
だけど
皆さんも何でもいいから一つをゴクリ
してみたらどうでしょ
自分で何ができるのか思いつかなかったら
私はなんだか楽しそうにしてるだけでも
それは恩送りになるんじゃないかなぁって
思う
この写真
楽しそうじゃないですか
あの福祉の仕事って大変でつらいとかって
いう話があるので福祉の仕事したいって
言うと今すっごい少ないんです深刻なん
です
でもこんなふうに楽しそうに捨てる写真
見るだけではなんか自分もやってみたい
なーなんて
思ってくれるんじゃないかなと
そしたらここで楽しそうにやってる人達は
自分たちでは意識してないのかもしれない
けどでもなんかちょっと役に立ってるん
じゃないのかな
思います
でねっ
その恩送り自分では
ちゃんと遅れてるのかわからないかもしれ
ないそのご夫婦はその手紙がこんなにも私
に元気をくれていることを全く知りません
自分の音クリがどういうふうに伝わって
いるのかは分からないかも知れ
でも
まず自分の
自分が恩送りをすした
それだけで
今自分がいる意義っていうのができあがる
んじゃないでしょうか
その後を送っていくことっていっぱいある
けれどもまず自分が送り出す
それだけで随分違うんじゃないかなと思い
ます
この楽しいって
みんながじゃあいつでも楽しいかった
そんなことないんですよねどんなに心の中
で楽しいと思っても楽しそうに見えなかっ
たら意味がない逆にちょっとあんまり
楽しくなくても楽しそうにしていればそれ
は意義があるんじゃないかな
いいと思ったことちょっとだけ楽しそうに
やってみるちょっと意識してみる私も
いろいろ大変でもうなんだかなということ
を今でもいっぱいありますでもそんなとき
にもちょっと意識するだけで気持ちは全然
違うんだと思うしそこから必ず
自分の周りが変わっていきます
それは断言できます
その後またそれを送っていくとそれは
どんどん広がっていくことだと思います
ぜひ一緒に私は福祉でもみんなはそんな
違うことでも全然構いませ
自分のところからそんなお送りしていけ
たらいいなと思います今日はどうも
ありがとうございました